but the boycotts are working yeah Disney
Disney's Shares are are are at risk
because of news reporting about there's
another boycott happening and they're
starting to freak out Target lost for
the first time in six years massive
amounts of money and their stock dropped
by like 27 but light is on the verge is
uh collapsing there's that's fair enough
but Apple there was one point in the in
the past couple years where Apple had
more actual cash than the federal
government that's wild like that's that
was a real thing so whereas yes I I get
like boycotts can can move the needle
and stuff uh I'm not sure apple is who
yeah I don't want to be able to because
look that is more of a global company
too they're they're selling iPhones all
over the you know the whole world so I
mean and hey I'm I'm I'm only telling
you my impression it's I was wrong about
the Bud Light uh boycott in the first
place I didn't think it was a good idea
and apparently I was wrong about that so
fair enough